hi I'm Steve and I have you ever
wondered how a search engine works let's
take a journey now when you post content
to Internet you post it on the site and
the internet is made up of many many
many many sites and these sites are
connected via links now what the system
does is create a sort of web and a
search engine like Google or Yahoo
employs a spider bot and not just one
spider bot a series of smaller spider
BOTS a spider bot is basically a program
that goes through the net looking for
content words and information to post to
their servers now on a site a meta tag
tells a spider bot when there's a good
information and key information on the
site and also when there's information
that you do not want to actually post to
a search engine when inspired by thats
collecting enough information it takes
that information and deposit it in the
index the index is basically a warehouse
for all information from here to
actually be stored then when you the
user performs a search called a query
your search goes to the warehouse which
then returns to you a list of different
sites this process goes on every day on
internet and that is a magic of a search
engine